you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau coup de fil vous trouvez pas que
certaines histoires films pièces sous
vraiment hardcore je pense par exemple à
oedipe soit le mec qui m'a tuer son père
couché avec sa mère et se crever les
yeux dans le plus grand calme
c'est le tiens je te parle des grosses
tragédie mais ne sont pas là que pour
nous secouer
elles sont là aussi pour le faire vivre
la catharsis d'aristote à rester
philosophe grec disciple de platon qui
s'intéressait à beaucoup de choses ça va
passer à l'art aux sciences que vous
avez pu le voir chez y penser il a même
inventé la métaphysique
voilà rien que ça il a créé la logique
la biologie bref c'est un personnage
super intéressant il nous dit qu'une
parfois nous sommes sujets à une
épuration des passions qu'ils appellent
catharsis
pour que la catharsis fonctionne il faut
deux choses d'abord il faut qu'on puisse
s'identifier aux acteurs des tragédies
que ce soit au cinéma au théâtre ou dans
la littérature
et pour ça c'est pas compliqué il faut
que les personnages et des vies ou des
réactions que l'on pourrait avoir
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est tout ce qui
lui arrive mais simplement oui mais je
ne sais pas je me sens connectée c'est
peut-être à cause des routes larges
il faut donc il ya une limitation de la
vie dans la représentation scénique et
ça tombe bien ça porte un nom c'est la
mimésis me disent non c'est tout j'ai
trouvé juste que ça avait un nom de
pokémon
la seconde chose ces cas restent dit que
quand tu regardes une représentation qui
t'inspire terreur ou pitié ça n'a pas du
tout la même intensité que dans la
réalité
eh ben dis donc qui fait pas peur ce
film
donc du fait qu'on peut regarder une
scène horrible et la supporter on va
pouvoir avoir une prise de conscience et
c'est ça pour aristote qui permet de te
purger des émotions
évidemment c'est les émotions qui sont
en rapport avec la scène par exemple
pour la scène horrible ça va permettre
de te purgé de la peur ensuite pour
l'aspect moral de la catharsis c'est à
dire se purger des mauvaises passions et
bien quand tu va regarder certains films
tu vas voir le destin tragique de
personnages et comme tu vises qu'ils
vivent par procuration c'est à dire à
travers eux eh bien tu va rejeter les
passions qui sont à l'origine de leur
destin tragique et comme ça tu te purge
de ses passions par exemple dans le film
scarface normalement t'as pas envie de
finir comme lui du coup tu vas pas
commencer à vendre de la coke est
malhonnête hors-la-loi avoir une soif de
pouvoir etc etc
après tu vas me dire que ça peut aussi
pousser à avoir des passions mauvaise et
je veux dire que c'est un risque et que
c'est un débat très court sommes en jeu
vidéo par exemple pour gta 5
est-ce que ça me permet de purger mes
passions ou est-ce que ça va me pousser
à commettre des crimes
on peut voir aussi la catharsis sous un
angle éducatif puisque ça va nous
apprendre à pratiquer nos émotions et
donc à les apprivoiser et du coup on va
diminuer notre sensibilité pour être
prêt à affronter le monde qui nous
entoure
moi je me sens pas les deux fois par son
corps et elles n'ont censuré ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le terme est
repris en psychanalyse et que ça désigne
en fait une méthode paris closes pour
libérer des émotions enfouies
j'espère que la catharsis et maintenant
un concept plus clair pour vous en tout
cas n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo ça
vous a plu
et à regarder les autres vidéos pour
apprendre d'autres coulent moi je
t'envoie du loch et de la piste
m
c'est qu'on était passé merci